[Music]
first on cbs this morning we're hearing
from a former facebook employee who says
the tech giant
has a diversity problem in its hiring
practices
rhett lindsay claims the predominantly
white leadership at facebook
has created a toxic work environment
focused on quotas based on race
separately the equal employment
opportunity commission is looking into
facebook's hiring methods
the social network tells cbs this
morning that increasing diversity at the
company
is a priority our national correspondent
jericha duncan is here with more on that
story jerica good morning michelle good
morning to you
lindsay worked at facebook for just
under a year he was hired
in 2020 to recruit diverse talent but
lindsey says he quickly found the
company's recruiting tactics
troubling the goal was to truly work at
a company where i could have great
impact
and i felt the time that facebook's
platform was the place where i can do
that
but when fully embedded in his new
position 32-year-old rhett lindsey says
he discovered what he calls
a problematic workplace and a culture
focused on quotas
it's the issue of not reaching out
because you're possibly the best fit for
the role
it's reaching out because you're a black
person and all i'm caring about is
trying to hit
my metric goal for the week on how much
outreach i've had to
diverse candidates and does that
translate though
into people getting jobs so
not necessarily and is that the problem
that's the problem
and what i would normally do is start
off by the skill set lindsey says he
reached a breaking point last
august when a song repeatedly using the
n word
was played during an online diversity
recruiting meeting
it goes back to leadership they deemed
that okay to play that in a diversity
recruiting meeting
where they be at we're talking about
trying to find black talent
and you're playing a song that says
where the at how hurt were you by that
i was extremely hurt i felt betrayed
by the company that i was proud to work
at
cbs news reviewed the video and saw
messages lindsey posted that everyone
could see
voicing his frustration in one message
lindsay wrote
why are you playing a song that is
literally saying the n word
come on i was leaving live comments that
the person that led the meeting could
see
people could see and there was people
leaving reactions to my comments
lindsay says his comments were not
addressed until the meeting ended
and the apology didn't come from the
white man who was playing the song
no it did not it came from a black woman
who was on that meeting
correct she spoke for the majority it
was
we apologize we're sorry in recent years
facebook has publicly pledged to put a
greater emphasis on diversity and
inclusion
the company's 2020 diversity report
shows the social network has been slowly
increasing representation over the past
seven years
from 2 percent of employees being black
to now
3.9 percent facebook tells cbs news it
plans to
increase the number of black people in
leadership roles in the u.s
by 30 percent by 2025.
still lindsey claims the hiring process
is flawed
due in part to what he says is
facebook's use of culture fit when
assessing candidates
the company denies using the practice
what is a
culture fit cultural fit is
identifying someone that blends well
with what's already established
evelyn carter is managing director at
paradigm
the strategy firm works with over 600
companies
seeking to diversify their workplaces
the problem is that culture fit
often turns into what some companies
literally call the beer test
right would i want to go out and have a
beer with you after work
that's a great criterion for finding a
new friend not so much for evaluating a
candidate for hire
since leaving facebook last november
lindsay started his
own consulting company with a focus on
diverse hiring
diversity is not just someone's skin
color and gender diversity is everyone's
background their experiences their
culture
their aspirations their identity are you
encouraged at all
by telling your story that facebook will
see this
and make changes my hope is that
facebook leadership
can reflect because it's my story uh
and my perspective but there's also
other people's perspectives
of their experiences at facebook that
they need to listen to
and the expert we spoke to says hiring
bias is not unique to facebook
and that we all have biases that we're
unaware of in a statement
facebook told cbs news they take
seriously allegations of discrimination
and have robust policies in place for
employees to report concerns and late
last night facebook
also told us they have reviewed the song
incident
and are taking appropriate action yeah
so many companies facing this issue
right now yes what's remarkable is that
song was
playing and he is in the chat saying
live what's up like who's doing this and
it was only after the meeting ended that
he had somebody respond to his concerns
correct all right jerica thank you